la falta de acción de la policía ante el
atacante que mató a 19 niños y dos
profesoras en una escuela de uvalde en
Texas el pasado 24 de mayo quedó en
evidencia en un video difundido por
medios de comunicación locales
para ser sincero no sé si realmente
quiero verlo no puede ser bonito no
puede ser agradable Así que
probablemente veré todo lo que pueda
pero no lo quiero
de lo que he visto en las noticias estos
agentes todos estos oficiales tenían sus
escudos sus armas todo su equipo de
protección y no hicieron nada no
hicieron nada el video comienza con la
llegada del atacante a las 11:33 de la
mañana en una esquina del pasillo
aparece un niño quien lo ve a apuntar su
arma a un salón de clase y abrir fuego
a partir de este momento los disparos se
suceden durante tres minutos hasta que
llegan los primeros policías a las 11:36
se dirigen hacia el aula pero oyendo los
disparos se retiran a una esquina
36 minutos después siguen en el mismo
lugar
uno de ellos Incluso se sirve gel
hidroalcogólico un detalle condenatorio
comentado en Twitter por la fundadora
demont action una organización que hace
campaña por una regulación más estricta
de las armas the statesman acaba de
publicar las imágenes de vigilancia del
tiroteo masivo en una escuela de uvalde
en las que se ve a la policía con equipo
de balística esperando en el pasillo de
la escuela e incluso parándose para
ponerse gel desinfectante mientras los
niños y las profesoras son masacrados a
las 12:50 se escuchan disparos un equipo
a finalmente matado al asesino varias
investigaciones fueron abiertas sobre el
papel de la policía de la masacre pero
sus conclusiones no se han hecho
públicas